summer in Port Sudan is a mixture of
heat humidity and dust many normally
travel elsewhere to a cooler climate but
this year the city is crowded thousands
have led the months of fighting in
Khartoum and Western Sudan are here some
of them are people with resources ideas
and a will to make a difference such as
Bushra Ahmed from North Korea
in just two months he managed to
recreate the theme restaurant he was
forced to abandon in cartoon
a section of the restaurant was burnt
and the rest is used by rsf as a
residence there was nothing we could do
about it and had no choice but to live
but he's happy and says he's making much
more profit from the new restaurant
small businesses like this one are being
launched all over the city and
attracting a lot of visitors
thanks to the novelty of the brand and
the quality of the service
[Music]
the twins Cafe is also a resurrection of
its lost Khartoum original
[Music]
there are five branches in Khartoum are
all gone as soon as we arrived here we
launched this Branch I'm surprised by
the large number of visitors
everything
he makes sure to entertain families
while serving their favorite foods from
back home most are from Khartoum
Ian we're extremely angry at what's
happening back home but we also had to
come here to lift up our Spirits a bit
so we don't give in to despair
[Music]
at the State Theater a band from cartoon
sings for peace
dramatic performances by displaced
artists focus on the horrors of violence
and disunity
outdoor social life has never been so
energetic at the peak of Summer says
this owner of a tourist Boat restaurant
we benefited a lot from the people who
came from they brought some good ideas
and contributed to the economy here
and in the opinion of displaced people
such as Ahmed who now makes a living
fixing mobile phones all the Sudanese
need is peace once they have that they
can rebuild their Nation on their own
Muhammad Al Jazeera Port Sudan